walk in to this video playing passer
putzi player puts our player ok so the
English should defense here will be six
tricky opening let's see what I can
accomplish yeah that's it's a line that
i think is quite ok for like nothing
much to worry about
pawn takes yeah here 96 is important not
Bishop before or something this is some
this is really okay now Bishop to c5 is
it's a very interesting way to play
nigera can be a very problematic for
white I'm actually threatening that now
so he has to play age three was some
move addressing IG form not sure what
else he can do but h3 is a very normal
move yeah TM many address 95 is one of
them tried for four active piece play
this for Queen age five Bishop f4 maybe
maybe just Bishop a foil I don't really
know if I can play Knight g6 I goes to
f4
night 2 D 3 maybe okay night b5 might be
rotating this fireplace 63 well before
it's not really a move that helps am
much thickening c4 but maybe he's really
a too annoyed by this Bishop p.m. on c5
certainly possible okay or 2d six
maybe g6 not easy happy now that I think
of it I should have come to eat somethin
so that i can play c5 easier but i still
will do that the ideas nights is 690
form and the bishop only seven is not
vulnerable then if you look the one for
example than my by bishop wouldn't hang
Oh interesting okay so I do my dad at
all this isn't this quite nice now still
I mean I'm controlling me five nicely
here and hmm don't really night c6 se5
mmm ok
yeah I know this is a nothing move but I
did loops I didn't I didn't see anything
grade Jeff d6 is really ugly chess and
not helping if I ever move this night
he's always going if I if that's really
that's really a very annoying this is
really i don't know i don't know i don't
want to move me five away but I don't
see a plan here
okay I really don't like it but I didn't
see anything else him
are you threatening on e5 and in only
six at the end that's that's not good
you five maybe hmm no no no this is I
really really played like I don't know
what don't know exactly what I played it
like but not not well I really didn't
have a plan ham and this sometimes
really backfires not all of the time
sometimes having no plan is not so bad
so that you don't screw something up but
most of the time having a plan is
helpful okay I think this this could
have been worse I'm not saying that it's
great but at least he has now this
doubled rooks and that don't don't do
that much
yeah I know I have this great bishop on
the edge but not much that I can do
about it at the moment try to provoke
weaknesses here for Nyjah for for
example now for night age five and I
have some ideas here at least I'm on the
on the King side that's some some way to
get well the bishop at least that
protects at least is six yeah that's
that's at least something helpful okay
going to take that and now double here
and Bishop d7
hmm yeah okay I have to do this I guess
at some point without this Bishop rook
ace man maybe did I bishop d8 that sets
even a quite good idea 58 I can do this
threatening to take and on g3 and back
okay okay I'm glad to get this end
Bishop just I can just tell anyone I
just take it but i don't know maybe i
can use it for something c4 Bishop c5
this kind of thing see form okay wow
that looks really weird getting allowing
me in there
can no no no no not so quick this is
hanging but I can also do this I have no
time I have no time whatsoever where did
I spend this time I had more time on the
clock and went first at least ok
spending lots of time now himself that
it's good I'm just gambling him ok check
I with all the pawns
check check game dryad no time on the
clock I probably should have kept Queens
on trying to try to win here I can win
with Bishop f3r okay whatever prayer
four major this is this is a mate threat
this is the big issue ad was a was a
total total mess around him chatter of
god I'm just winning all the plants but
I have 12 seconds but he really was
quick yeah normally yeah my pre moves
are normally really really quick but he
he was just as as quick as I was I
really thought that I might win it on
time but it didn't didn't work out whoo
okay thanks for watching